apenas se reincorporaban a sus
actividades los mexicanos este 19 de
septiembre luego del simulacro de sismo
que tuvo lugar este ejercicio a las 12
con 19 en conmemoración de los
terremotos de 1985 y de 2017 en esta
misma fecha 19 de septiembre cuando a la
una con cinco de la tarde sonó de nueva
cuenta la alerta sísmica pero en esta
ocasión no se trataba de un nuevo
simulacro como algunas personas pudieron
pensar sino que se trataba de un sismo
real otra vez en 19 de septiembre un
sismo con Epicentro en el municipio de
coalcomán en el Estado de Michoacán y
cuya magnitud se ha ido actualizando
comenzó en 6.8 grados y el más reciente
reporte del sismológico nacional
determina que se trató de un sismo de
7.7 grados en escala richter un fuerte
sismo que se sintió en prácticamente
toda la República Mexicana Incluso en
lugares donde tenía tiempo que no se
sentían un sismo y con un saldo
preliminar que no fue cuantioso o no ha
sido cuantioso En comparación con los
terremotos anteriores en esta ocasión se
reporta el fallecimiento de una persona
en Manzanillo en el Estado de Colima por
la caída de una barda en un centro
comercial en la Ciudad de México la jefa
de gobierno Claudia sheinbaum reporta
saldo blanco afectaciones en algunos
inmuebles Pero lo que sí hubo Pues fue
muchas crisis nerviosas llamadas de
emergencia por crisis nerviosas de
personas que Pues quizá han perdido
algún Familiar o han vivido alguna
situación lamentable en los terremotos
anteriores incluso algunas personas aún
no logran tener su vivienda de nuevo no
ha sido reconstruida después del sismo
de 2017 en la Ciudad de México cuando se
vivió de nueva cuenta una fecha sin duda
que los mexicanos seguirán recordando Y
seguirán viviendo con cierta angustia el
19 de septiembre